this is a production of cornell
university
really delighted today to introduce
three of
our really excellent scholars here at
cornell
that we'll be talking on the topic of
cobit 19 and the resilience of
global agricultural systems so we all
know that lots of things have changed
lots of things have been jeopardized a
lot of things have held up and we've
learned a lot of lessons
since since march about the the
resilience of our ag systems and how
covet 19
has played out in different parts of the
globe so
the what the panel will do today is
step through three geographic case
studies um
asia africa and upstate new york and
then we're going to pivot into some
pre-planned questions and then have some
time at the end
for for open uh q a so if you do have
questions
please if you think you're going to
forget them pop them into the chat
and we'll make sure that we've returned
to them at the end but i'm delighted to
have the the three excellent scholars
on the panel today rachel besner kerr is
a professor
in the department of global development
ed mabaya is a senior research associate
also in the department of global
development
and probably bengali is a professor in
the dyson school but also with a joint
appointment in global development
so rachel will be speaking about uh
upstate new york
ed focusing on africa and probably on
india the asian context and then they
will be fielding questions from more of
a global perspective
after they uh do some some case study
review for those geographies
so without any further ado thank you
very much for attending today
and we're going to work from east to
west so starting with with prabhu and
then ed and then rachel
so probably the floor is yours
all right great to be here
um excited to talk to the
soil and crop science seminars series
here
um as andrew said i'd like to talk about
asia and specifically about what's
happened with
the covet crisis and how it's affected
food systems in india let me give you a
bottom line here
my bottom line is i have been
enormously surprised by
how resilient the food systems in india
have been to the crisis
and i'll show you some data on that but
i've been been extremely concerned about
the humanitarian impact of the crisis
which has been primarily the result of
a reverse migration
of millions of poor people from
urban areas back to their rural
households
in a totally unplanned manner
and the government did not program this
and did not really think through the
implications of this
and the long-term impact of this reverse
migration is something that
we'll have to keep watching and seeing
what happens over time
the third impact i
see is long-term
chronic impacts on nutrition
especially child nutrition and that's
coming about
because of disruptions and
some of the safety net programs
especially focused on children
in india today so i'll be coming to all
of those issues as we go through this
talk
which i hope to do very quickly but just
to give you
a timeline here um as you know the
crisis started
in december in china india got its first
case by the end of
january by mid-march there were about 50
cases in india
and then india went into an absolute
total lockdown
with less than 24 hours notice by march
25th
and it went through those lockdowns
tried to come out went back in and all
the way up till
mid august they were in the lockdown
mode and
finally just came out because there was
no way you can keep a billion people
locked down for
forever and um
and you know during that period of
lockdown
the indian coveted numbers were actually
not too bad but once the lockdown
stopped those numbers of skyrockets
skyrocketed and today india is i think
number three or number two depending on
who's counting
in terms of total number of cases around
the world so it's it's a massive problem
it's an ongoing problem
um that we're observing and and my group
the data cornell institute
is keeping a track of this as we go
along
um just to start with an advertisement
um we put out a fairly detailed report
on
pandemic prices and their implications
for nutrition security in india
a fairly data intensive document that's
available on our website
that document went up till
end of may and we haven't updated it but
we've been keeping track of the data
since then
so we hope we'll be able to do an
updated
version of this document which basically
looks at
what's happened to food supply food
prices
um the urban food supply chain
and then looked at the safety net
programs in india the
the subsidized food grain distribution
system the
public distribution system the pds and
also
the the child development program
uh in india which is a very large
integrated child development program
that runs across
rural areas in india and and how that's
been fairing and the midday meal scheme
in schools in india which is a really
important part of
nutrition and how they've been the big
story of course is the reverse migration
and the loss of income and remittances
which we talked through
also and so those of you are interested
it's available on the
the tata cornell institute website and
you can download it for free
so one of the the the issues that we've
looked at in great detail
is what's happening to urban food prices
so we tracked
major urban food markets
across the country and we've tracked
them on a weekly basis
from march all the way through we're
still
doing the tracking now and we've tracked
them for all the major commodities and
i'm just giving you some examples here
we track them for stable grains
for pulses which is a really important
part of the protein
diet in india vegetables meat milk
etc and what we've done is we've
compared
the weekly data against the same week
last year
to see what the differences have been
and interestingly enough if you look at
staples there's been
very marginal change that took place in
staple grains
and also fairly small change in pulses
the bigger change has been in um sorry
the bigger change has been in vegetables
vegetables
saw a fairly dramatic shift
upwards in prices uh during the
early part of the the
lockdown period but then after that
um by mid-may
prices started to come down quite
significantly and today vegetable prices
are fairly close to
what they were at the same time last
year
and and that's because
the government very quickly made a
decision that
if we want to keep urban populations
food secure and happy
we better open up the food markets and
so they made
food mark food traders
essential service providers and so
the supply chains that were broken in
the early part of the
lockdown opened up and so you began to
see supplies coming in
and markets functioning fairly regularly
um with with or without masks for
people who are going to them and so
prices came down
quite significantly after that
now the real challenge has been
with employment and and you see
here oops sorry now you see that um
there was a sharp rise in unemployment
rates that took place
just as the lockdown happened and
and the primary reason for that is a
large part of
the labor force
is this casual labor daily labor
semi-skilled labor that's migrated from
rural areas into urban areas
and and even in rural areas in the
smaller towns etc much of the labor
that's employed is in this
non-contractual or semi-contractual
arrangements
so when the lockdown happened all of
those jobs
disappeared overnight and and then
that started this massive movement of
populations
back into rural areas and there was no
transport systems
no railways no buses nothing so a lot of
people actually
walked several days to get back it was
fairly sad and major
humanitarian disaster
when you think about it and think about
how that had happened
but the longer term implications of that
was it had
a significant in effect on the income
that goes to rural households
because with the loss in employment
much of the the remittance income that
rural households depend on for their
food consumption
and other consumption dropped overnight
and you saw a big drop
in overall consumption that happened
they we've been using monthly data that
comes out of
the survey that cuts across the whole
country
uh it's a consumer monitoring survey
and we're waiting the last round that we
have access to is from june and so we're
looking for we'll be waiting for the
next round to come in
and what we saw initially was this
dramatic drop
in in overall food expenditures
for all the different food groups and
what's interesting is that the drop for
staples
was much smaller than the drop for some
of the other major food groups
and also interesting is the drop in
food consumption was much higher in
urban areas
than in rural areas but i suspect we're
going to see a change
now we're going to as we see the next
round coming in
i think the bigger change we'll see is
in some of the more
nutritious food groups such as
vegetables pulses etc and rural areas
relative to urban areas and that's
primarily because of this
income change that's happened this
remittance income once we get the next
round of data we'll be able to separate
out the effect of the
supply chain disruption and the price
rise
relative to the income drop and my
hypothesis
is that that income drop is going to be
a much bigger
driver of the consumption change that
we're going to see
um what happened to the safety net
programs
now so as i mentioned earlier the the
public distribution system of subsidized
food grains
is one of the largest safety net
programs in the world
that india provides around 15 kg
of free or almost free rice or wheat to
to every household in rural areas in
india per month
now with the when the crisis happened
because of this movement of populations
back into rural areas they actually
added another
15 kg additional amounts to this
subsidized grain that was provided we've
done a telephone survey across
a sample of households that we've been
working with in india
and we've asked specifically about their
access to this subsidized grain and all
of them
i mean generally the majority reported
that they had
no problem in getting access to this
grain and so
from a purely hunger point of view
calorie hunger point of view
we've not seen a dramatic
increase in hunger in india despite the
crisis
so that's actually good news but on the
bad news side
the drop in the icds program
which runs the child welfare schemes and
child nutrition schemes those programs
were closed down
and the midday meal program in schools
was closed down
and so access to food and nutrition for
children became a major issue and
continues to be a major issue
so my concern is not
so much about hunger my concern is
long-term nutritional implications for
children especially children under five
and
then the effects on stunting etc
that can come in from that
and and of course the migration issue
continues to be
a major concern as we look ahead
many of these people are still in rural
areas they haven't
gone back into the cities the cities
haven't
generated that employment opportunities
as they used to in the past and so you
still have a whole
set of family members who are stuck
stuck in
at home and they need to be fed
but they're also going to start
competing in the rural labor market
and this can have a fairly depressing
effect on
wages and rural areas it can also
affect marginal working population
especially
rural women who depend on
employment for weeding and harvesting
and transplanting
etc for their incomes and now that
there's additional family labor
available at home much of the
direct employment for these rural women
may be
affected so i'm really concerned about
what are some of the
the longer term implications of this
reverse migration that's happened
and whether we can create new
and uh and better employment
opportunities for these populations
in the villages or in the
neighborhood towns etc rather than
having them go all the way back into
mumbai and
delhi etc that's a challenge i think the
government needs to be thinking through
so basically from
[Music]
to conclude on the implications for food
security
i think the staple grain prices have
remained
fairly stable and the vegetables and
other nutritional crops are coming
back towards uh normal trends so it
seeks it speaks to fairly significant
resilience for the food system itself
uh whether the supply disruptions
will continue into the future in urban
areas
if this crisis continues is a question
mark but my
in my view i think we're not going to
see that disruptions in food supplies
what we're going to see is the
implications for
unemployment continuing to be high the
loss of remittance income
continuing to be high and that affects
food access
and diets and diet diversity
and the impact of the shock on diet
quality
is something that we should be worried
about especially when you think about
children and child nutrition
so those of you who are interested in a
deeper dive into the india situation
there's a lot of material on our website
we have a whole dedicated section on
covet 19 so i'd invite you to
check us out there thank you andrew
great thank you so much prabhu and so
we'll be returning to
questions for prabhu's presentation at
the end
and i'll invite ed mobile to to upload
his
presentation yeah so
uh while that is uh being done i just
wanted to start with the qualify
and say that um a large part of what uh
problem
presented for india uh based on
similarity with what's happening
in africa as well so there will be some
a little bit of an overlap
the second qualifier being that
the africa is a large continent
so i'm painting with very broad brush
you know what is 54 countries and i'll
speak much more to
sub-saharan africa so there won't be as
many numbers because you know this is
very generalized stylized effect of
new evidence that we were getting from
africa so
i want to make five key points in this
uh opening segment
and this is as follows the first point i
want to make is
we have kind of the africa situation in
terms of the pandemic itself
is still very much a mystery or at least
to me i've not had any
really convincing one narrative on why
africa has somewhat been spread to date
in terms of the epidemiology itself
there are many theories out there but
what i'm showing you right now
is the cumulative cases uh from john
hopkins uh
coronavares resource center so you can
see from this map
the map of africa is very much lower
numbers in terms of cumulative cases
compared to look at the the u.s for
example in europe
so this is quite an anomaly uh you know
usually
on most maps africa is a red one and the
rest of the world is you know
usually the green the green side when
you look at the
incidence rate so this is divided by
population
you see that it's even even less the
case
so we still have this big anomaly that
many theories have been proposed
on why africa has not been affected this
much i'll mention a few of them here one
of them was
the bcg vaccine another one is the warm
climate in africa
uh another one is uh relatively youthful
population with africa having
more than three quarters of the
continent under the age of 35.
uh i would say collectively they might
start to explain something but
i don't think they are anywhere close to
explaining the anomalies even within
africa itself
so for example you have progress in
south africa in kenya
and some people have said justice lack
of measurement you know
like uh you know there's very little
testing in some of this but you'd also
think that hospitals would be starting
to fill up by now
another group that i've had you know in
starting to gain momentum now is
maybe people have not given enough
credit to key decisions that were made
by african leaders
uh that uh africa closed down borders in
much of this year and they already was
very little movement
so the diseased lord there was law from
the beginning
and maybe that's a lesson that we need
to be sharing with the rest of the world
i will not try to speculate on to which
of us
is correct but it suffices you to say
that in terms of disease lord itself
africa right now is a very very low
incidence
i hope that it continues this way but
this is what we know
we know as of now so that said
the impact of the uh pandemic itself has
been much more indirect
through the uh agricultural sector so
i'll show two more slides and i'll speak
more freely on some of my talking points
that i have
one key uh you know you know a lot of
evidence is coming in now from different
sources but this is just very recent
this came out
last month in nature he's talking about
you know with this last point that i
made the closure of national boundaries
in africa came with a lot of disruption
in movement of people
and it looks like this is having a lot
of effects on the planting season for
most crops now in africa
so by every estimate the disruption in
step of food supply especially for maize
and rice
inputs usually come from urban areas go
to rural areas and
products move from rural areas quarter
urban areas
all that has been disrupted at local
level domestic level and the regional
level
and this is likely to have significant
effects if not now
in the next season on amount of food
that is available out there
this report goes on the show i mean this
just shows you the two main step-up
crops
of rice and maize and you can see there
the
uh the impact on the growing season
you know when covered heat in early
march and april
it was really a key part of the planting
season and that was disrupted
and this we're likely to see this effect
uh in a few months from now so this is
something that
you know i disrupted the production
system for most of the stepper crops
i happened to be the african development
bank when coveted 19 was declared a
global pandemic
and one of my last tasks at the african
development bank
i actually delivered this to the board
in june was to develop a strategy for
the feed africa response to covet 19
that was going to be implemented
across the continent the key
measurements
that we came up with to minimize
disruption of
our food food flow in africa were eight
key areas
i'll just go through them here because
they kind of capture the
the thinking around that time some of
which has changed
so we decided we were going to invest in
about eight key priority areas
the bank was putting up about 10 billion
dollars
to help african countries cope with this
pandemic
so we did uh supporting for food
delivery especially targeting the poor
and vulnerable populations
we also supported governments in
creating uh stabilization of food prices
either by releasing food from strategic
grain reserves
we supported efforts to increase
localized food production system we knew
that
and i'll get it into this in a little
bit that localized food product you know
it's more likely to be stable
and impact resilient compared to food
that was coming from abroad
we encouraged governments to invest a
lot in extension and advisory services
so that there was minimal disruption in
production tried as much as we could you
know there was still some significant
disruptions
post-harvesting agro-processing of
highly nutritious foods
so when you talk about fruits and
vegetables and meat highly perishable
goods
we realized we needed to invest a lot of
resources into
preserving the flow of those also policy
support for free flow of food and other
inputs we had to declare for most
countries that food was
essential service so we created green
channels through which
food could flow uh from country to
country in within countries
and spread from the many of the
quarantine measures that were in place
we established some food security task
forces that were regional level
and also supported several other
regional initiatives
i will stop sharing my screen now so i
can actually see and talk to the people
and i will make three more points about
what this pandemic did for food security
in africa
so important to note that the pandemic
came on top of
already existing uh food insecurity on
the continent
africa was already battling with upwards
of 74 million people who were food
insecure there was already a climate
shock you know a lot of climate change
there was conflict
we were dealing with the locust invasion
that had taken all all the horn of
africa we were dealing with foreign
so when this shock came it came on
pre-existing conditions that just made
things worse
and it may be hard to actually
disentangle these different effects from
covet 19
compared to what was already existing so
so that's something important to note
another point is that these actually
turns out to be
a zero-sum game when it comes to public
resources
uh this is something that hit us very
very quickly that you know
when you're talking about governments
even development community
they have a limited budget so what you
take from
what you put money into health into
education
you have to take that money from
somewhere uh
governments we're faced with this
critical decision we love agriculture
but this is a health crisis
so ministers of health had the biggest
you know voice
and most of the resources went to health
first and we really had to campaign hard
to say that
look this is more of a food crisis
pandemic for africa then it is a you
know a health crisis
and you really have to fight for those
resources across the different other
sectors as well so
there was a lot of this back and forth
depend on where governments were going
to allocate their money
lastly i want to speak more to which
groups have been most affected by this
in terms of africa the evidence is still
coming and you know i
want to underscore this point that we're
not just at the beginning of this
pandemic so any conclusions that we make
now are
likely to be premature but the evidence
that we're seeing so far
in the usa you know is that low income
households have been affected the most
almost by definition low income muscles
have been the most vulnerable
at the beginning of the pandemic there
was a rush to buy food
the most households to stock up and hold
up you know
much like what you did toilet paper it
was happening in africa shelves were
getting cleared up
but poor people who live from you know
and tend to mouth do not have that kind
of money so when the shelves were
initially emptied
prices went up and poor people did not
have money to buy and stock up in there
you know they don't even have
refrigerators
to keep their food in so you are seeing
a large part of the
affected population being the most poor
and vulnerable populations
within that subgroup you also have
women and children you know all the
evidence that we're seeing here is
being the most affected and i'll say
when you compare rural to urban
households
rural households at least at the
advantage that they'd localize food
production system so they're a little
bit more resilient
but the large part of africa's urban
population was
employed in the informal sector and once
they lost their flow of income
they did not have any requests to you
know income that they could use to
purchase food
and they did not have the capabilities
to grow their own food
so most of them either if they still had
connections to rural areas
they migrated back to their parents home
in the rural areas
increasing the pressure they are much
like prabhu mentioned for india as well
so you're seeing a large part of this
human movement from rural urban areas
and you're seeing the most vulnerable
groups bearing the brand of this
pandemic in terms of
food insecurity i'll leave it there for
now and we'll get back to other points
related to this thanks
excellent thank you so much ed and i'm
over to you rachel
um so uh thank you very much and it's
an honor to be presenting here and today
i'm
presenting on something that's quite
different from my usual
focus um uh because most of my
work is in is in malawi and
in southern africa but i have
had the the privilege of working
in new york as a volunteer around covet
19
and the food systems that's why i was
asked to present on new york
um and uh it we go from
a continent to a country and now to a
region of uh a state so
and and one that you all uh have uh
or many of you i don't want to make
assumptions about where you are now but
one all of many of you have experienced
directly so
it it's a real sweep today um
but i'm going to do a move from
food producer over to consumer and
looking at the food system
and uh just to say that my role in
in looking at new york um has been on
the tompkins county
uh covet 19 food task force which i uh
co-organized with rafa ponte
and uh the late uh kirby edmunds and um
and um uh cce
and and others um at the start of the
pandemic as a response to
trying to uh deal with the impacts on
the food system
so in in terms of food producers um
we know early on there was really
challenges in new york around
changes in markets as you had schools
closing as uh
restaurants uh shut down in the lockdown
that meant
a lot of uh markets that were normally
available
for producers were gone and we saw this
particularly with the dairy industry
with losing their
market in in schools and restaurants
they actually had to dump a significant
amount of their milk at the beginning of
the pandemic and that got a lot of
attention nationally and even
internationally
but there were other significant impacts
on producers and it really varied by
sector but
a recent survey that the new york state
government
um did found 65 percent of new york
farms were affected
negatively by the pandemic everything
from
labor shortages and this was
particularly an issue
for the fruit and vegetable industry
when you had
restrictions on migration and
movement into the country and within
states it
led to both shortages and uncertainty
about labor uh supply
and then this real shift in uh demand
and market opportunities so both
soaring demand in some areas for example
in local meat there was a really
a steep increase in in local demand for
or demand for local meat and um
reduced uh demand in for example uh
restaurants and other other institutions
that used to be
available so some local
fruit and vegetable producers who had a
range of
options who had a range of markets
normally
they were able to adjust but others who
depended on some of these institutional
sources really
struggled and and so there's a lot of
variation in the impact and how it was
felt
but often a need to pivot in the way
that
uh their product was sold and and
sometimes that meant learning new skills
learning how to market things online
learning how to work through new
distributors
and and so real steep learning curve and
for
those who are planting uh crop
based producers often at a time when
they were having to plan
at the beginning of the season what to
plant so real
really high stress circumstance for
farmers
for producers across the state and
um this wasn't only felt for producers
it was really
felt for farm workers and farm workers
were
particularly vulnerable to the impacts
of coven 19
in part because of their own often
precarious
uh employment conditions they initially
lacked
information about ppe and cova 19
and the cornell farm worker program
which is
here at cornell has has been really
essential in providing some
critical information to farm workers um
and really trying to to connect with
them as there was a lot of
confusion and uncertainty but also their
own living conditions
made it difficult if there was a case
it often spread quickly and there was
some high-profile cases
at the beginning of the pandemic that
drew attention to this issue
hard to isolate and um
hard to prevent spread and then
because of their own employment
conditions sometimes a lack of access to
health care
and testing um which um a number of
organizations working with farm workers
like the farmworker program here
here in ithaca uh really tried to and in
the surrounding region really trying to
alleviate but an ongoing challenge uh
for for that particular uh sector within
our
within our uh community that is not
always visible to us even though they're
a crucial part of the food system
um thinking about food retail uh there
was
a real shift and we all felt it you know
ed talked about you know the the rush on
on
uh food and uh different uh supplies and
we certainly saw that in our own grocery
stores here in new york state
at the same time we saw a real loss of
jobs for many people working in the food
service industry
and a shift towards online delivery
and online orders
and a lot of small food retail
businesses restaurants and food
businesses closing um
so this all made for um
impacts on the consumer end but uh
inconsistent supplies in grocery
retailers and
supply chain disruptions and um
this so that was on the retail side but
then on the consumption side we have
sort of contrasting stories on the one
hand
there was this surge in interest in
joining community supported agriculture
in
buying local buying from local farmers
markets buying from local farms
in interest in home gardening and
canning there's been
shortages of canning supplies in the
grocery stores because of this interest
and a lot of kind of relearning home
food preparation so this is a happy
story for some
um but in contrast you have
rising disparities in access to healthy
food and a recent paper out of the
university of buffalo really highlighted
this
this uh disparity so uh
ordering food online is often more
expensive if you're
sick at home and you need to have food
delivered to your home that could
mean you can't access it easily snap
the um supplemental nutrition program
here in
the united states isn't always available
for online retail
and people had there was a rise in
unemployment so people had less money
available for purchasing food
there is shorter shopping hours that may
not be accessible for people who are
working several part-time jobs
and less food available when you get to
the grocery store
at times because of this supply chain
disruption and that was particularly in
the early period of the pandemic
as well as school food
disruptions now some school
programs were able to do home delivery
and in tompkins county we were
lucky that the school system really
shifted
and delivered food to kids
in at home throughout the early
lockdown period but all of this put
together
led to dramatic surge in food insecurity
in the united states and in new york uh
in particular
so this is
from feeding america but
there's a recent report um put together
by
um cornell cce and
um which also documents this
rise in food insecurity nationally um
from 11
to 23 and an estimated uh
in tompkins county uh an increase from
10.3 percent to 13 uh 13.6 percent
um these are preliminary numbers and i
know there's a lot of effort to try to
document it
at a national scale but nonetheless it's
been
well uh documented there is a dramatic
surge
in food insecurity and it's being felt
more acutely by particular groups of
households
so 38 of black households in
the united states are estimated to be
food insecure for example
um and and alongside this
is real challenges with emergency food
provision
in new york and and at a national scale
so we saw for the first few months of
the pandemic this dramatic
increase in the number of people looking
for
free food because they had lost their
job and they
they were facing you know serious
shortages
and they had many had never had to
access emergency food
prior to this pandemic and
there was a dramatic increase in the
amount of food
distributed through food banks which and
we saw this in some of the
early headlines in
the spring and the summer with long
lineups and waiting for
uh food distribution and combined with
the impacts in the retail food industry
there is a 70 decline in retail food
donations an estimated 70
decline and they are one of the major
two food banks
and and retail food groceries are some
of the major suppliers
of food to food banks and so this meant
that some food banks had to reduce the
amount provided to households so you
have
increase in demand and a decrease in
supply at the same time
and you also saw a reduction in
volunteers and staff shortages
in a number of food pantries
because many uh sort of older seniors
are those who staff
and volunteer at food pantries the real
challenge within the emergency
uh food world um particularly
rural food pantries uh preliminary
reports suggest that they've had
particular difficulties with
lineups and following uh you know
dealing
dealing with increased demand and a
addressing the kind of health
requirements and health guidelines
many of the places where food is
distributed are small spaces so a lot of
places had to
readjust and and find new ways of
delivering food in in this context
and alongside this you know sort of deep
challenges to the food system
we saw in new york and and in tompkins
county is no exception
uh a proliferation of real um
creative responses and a an
effort to address these needs in in our
communities
and many of you may have seen for
example these mutual
aid food boxes that were developed
and placed around the county
where people would put food and
other people who needed it would just
come and get it it was an informal
system that was developed and kind of a
rose out of out of need and interest in
helping each other
as i mentioned uh i along with a lot of
other players
put together this coven 19 food task
force
which included county government city
government
the southern tier
food bank the food bank of the southern
tier uh the
cce um cornell farm workers program
a whole range of different players came
together
working across the food system to talk
about what
challenges were being faced and how to
address them uh
together one of the initiatives that
came there was an initiative at the
state level
um called nourish new york but there was
a local initiative nourished tompkins
which was
getting local food from local food
producers and distributing it to a
number of different programs
to that were trying to make sure
low-income households had
access to healthy food during the
pandemic
the cornell farm workers program
developed a list of
i think it was over a thousand farm
workers their
cell phone numbers to be able to text
them information and keep them up to
date and there was a
group of volunteers who made homemade
masks and delivered it to them and there
has been
a real effort at delivering local food
to
and meals to farm workers who are in
isolation because of copenhagen so these
are
some examples of some really creative
strategies for addressing these uh
challenges during the pandemic and it
was really a combination of
you know non-profits local food
distributors some local companies
um this is an example from
a solidarity garden that was
planted uh with local farmers
and uh local non-profits uh
to make sure that people had access to
food
and so some inspiring stories as well
and
i think i'm well under my time i'm
looking at andy
so uh just to some initial conclusions
and as
ed and probably noted this is uh kind of
early days for having strong conclusions
about what's been happening
um in new york but these
initial food supply chain disruptions
and
you know concerns about high high amount
of waste because of the
shifts in markets those were kind of the
initial experiences of the pandemic but
then
there was a a successful
transitioning to new markets and
delivery systems i would say amongst
many producers
but serious challenges for small and
mid-sized producers and small and
mid-sized food retailers in this
environment
and i highlighted the kind of particular
vulnerability of farm workers
both in terms of health impacts and food
security impacts
during the pandemic and rising
disparities
rising rates of food insecurity and
rising disparities in terms of access to
healthy food
and so all of this points to a need to
coordinate
and communicate better across local and
regional food systems and strengthening
local and regional food systems much as
ed mentioned as a priority in the
african context
a need to ensure that we have a vibrant
local and regional food system to be
able to respond to these kinds of shocks
the the um pandemic also highlighted the
the really inspiring kind of
willingness of people to step outside of
their normal roles
and take on new ones and collaborate and
communicate across
sectors in in ways that were really
inspiring
at the same time as highlighting the
kind of fragility of
low-income households to shocks and
their
their the sort of lack of social safety
nets that really support
households during these kinds of shocks
to ensure that they are food secure and
are getting access to nutritious food so
this is a challenge
not only in india and in africa but also
here in new york state
with people of color
color and low income households really
suffering dramatically from food
insecurity and lack of access to
nutritious food
and even even though there is adequate
supply still within the food system so
i think those would be some of the key
take-home messages that i would
that i would um emphasize um i guess one
other point in terms of
small and mid-sized producers the um
the nourish new york program initially
really supported large-scale producers
and and
uh the coven 19 tompkins county kova 19
food task force um
really had a chance to discuss this with
the new york state
um organizers of that program and
in the hopes that the future program
if there's further efforts along these
lines that there's an
effort to try to support small and
mid-skies producers in these kinds of
programs and not just
focus on the food supply angle of that
program so
um that's another kind of take-home
message to keep an eye on small and
mid-sized producers as well
in in these kind of government programs
for ensuring access to healthy food
so with that i'm going to stop sharing
my screen
and um thanks thanks a lot rachel
we're almost at the end of our time so
i'm going to ask
one simple question and then if people
uh have the appetite to stay on for a
bit we'll we'll keep the session open
for 10 15 minutes so people
from the floor can ask questions but
this is
this has been an enormous stress test of
course for the agri-food systems
globally and probably some systemic
weaknesses have been
identified as well as areas of
unexpected strength
but for us as a research for development
community
i'm curious if if you all have uh some
insights on how we should be doing our
jobs differently has anything come up
that suggests that we need
new areas of research new forms of
research collaboration
or any other effort that really is
responsive
towards the resilience challenge that's
been illuminated by the covet 19
challenge
that's all three of you
turn taking is welcome i mean one of the
things we struggled with
in the task force was being able to
identify
who is vulnerable who is struggling with
food insecurity
um and how how to go about identifying
them um
i i saw that norman portillo was on the
call earlier and he was
he's been involved in this uh trying to
do a survey
locally and and so that you know being
able to quickly identify who's food
insecure
and and how to reach them is is a
challenge um
even even in a country like the united
states
i wasn't just talking um i'll make two
uh three very quick points here
the first one is that in africa
especially
the lack of real-time intelligence on
how much food is available
with was just shocking to me we
rely on we in research all of us you
know we're happy with fao starts from
2018
when this pandemic hits ministers of
agriculture struggling to find out
exactly how much price is in nigeria
much that this information is in the
hands of private companies
most of them are very small so we just
did not know
how much food is out there so it's very
hard to act
and develop policy and measures when you
have very little intelligence on what
the actual situation looks like
secondly you know i'll say for africa
where the food systems are highly
informal
we underestimated how much movement of
food is related to movement
of people uh a lot of food in africa
does not move on these 40-foot
containers
it caused by people making it to to
see my cousin in town i'm gonna take
this much food with me and if i'm going
from
urban to raw areas i'm gonna move with
food the moment you cut the movement of
food
of people inevitably you're gonna have a
significant impact
on the movement of food so as much as
you try to disentangle the two
they're very much intertwined especially
in developing countries
then the third lesson which requires a
little bit more research is that really
this look what this is the first would
say global pandemic that has happened
when the world was globalized
so occasionally with sharks in one part
of the world and more
food could move from one part into
another part
this is really making us relook at this
these
resilience of localized food systems
that people had started to ignore in a
way
we always knew our rice would somehow
get grown in canada and end up with some
people would have bred in zimbabwe and
we didn't pay attention to what happens
in between
for the first time people who were just
shocked that you know
this everybody was looking after
themselves in the first
three months all these countries were
panicking they said we're gonna take
care for
southwest before we start exporting
russia you know all these
big countries so it really made this uh
local politics and local governments
focus on local production and
almost a movement back to
self-sufficiency which has this downside
as well but it really highlighted the
importance of localized
food system in a pandemic like this one
so one thing that strikes me is um
you know as people working in food and
agriculture
we don't really think too much about
the rural urban integration not in terms
of food
supply chains which you think about a
lot but
thinking about how rural households
depend on
income coming from urban house urban
housings back to rural households and
remittances and and how
crucial that income is for
survival of rural households and food
security of rural households
i think that connection is often missed
and this crisis showed very clearly that
once you
cut that connection off rural food
insecurity goes through the roof
and people think about rural areas as
self-generating
food self-sufficient areas but the rural
markets depend a lot on remittances
coming from urban areas
and i think what one of the lessons
that comes out clearly is we need to
think about
employment security in a much bigger way
than we do right now
so if if a third of the employment
opportunities
in india are casual employment
without contracts and high risk
of termination at any point then that's
not a sustainable way to manage labor
markets
and we need to think about long-term
solutions for labor markets and even
think about
more regional more local
non-agricultural
employment opportunities which can then
substitute for these remittance flows
that
that have become so crucial for survival
the other point i want to make is this
crisis has shown quite clearly that
hunger is no longer an issue of calories
there's more than enough calories to go
around
and we don't we shouldn't stick to this
1960s paradigm which i'm
sorry agriculture scientists still stick
to which is
we don't have enough pile of grain well
we have more than enough piles of grain
what we don't have is a balanced food
system
that provides for an adequate diversity
of diets
and i think that's an area where we
should be thinking about a lot more
let me stop there excellent
thank you prabhu rachel and ed let me
open the floor
um chime in anybody who has a question
hi everyone you can oh i'm sorry oh good
good can you hear me okay i'm gonna
step away from here for a second so i
can take my mask off
and you all can hear me better um
my phone's going to die soon so i'm
going to ask this fairly quickly but
as there's so much hubbub about vaccines
coming out
soon and as that becomes apparent
and and it hits the market depending on
price
um if there are poor countries that need
to get their hands on the vaccine
do you foresee these people these
decision makers
may be prioritizing the vaccine
over food security or is there
limitations with receiving the vaccine
that may affect food security
coming up here in the next year
it's a very good question i don't know
if i don't if i have a good answer to
that i mean first of all
yes like the question the point that i
raised is that when you're talking from
a public
expenditure point of view there's a very
much a zero-sum game that people don't
like to admit
so money that goes the finite resources
so
the more you put money into one area
such as health
that money has to come from somewhere in
developing countries
is usually education health
and agriculture are some of the biggest
areas of expenditure so inevitably
there's likely to be implications that
if you put more money in health
you might be investing less in education
in uh
and in agriculture as well but i'm
hoping that there's gonna be a public
public effort to make sure that we
minimize uh that risk which
i'm glad you're pointing out but i'm not
sure how this is gonna play out it
depends what kind of vaccine they have
and it depends uh what kind of country
priorities look like
i don't know if probably
well my my response is quite simple the
share of
agriculture and the total budgets of
most countries is so tiny now
and compared to the share of the budget
for health
and other infrastructure so it can't get
worse than it is already
so we are already at the bottom in terms
of prices
other questions from the floor
i have one more um
probably you've talked a lot about
remittances
and labor markets and of course this is
also relevant to
all the other dimensions the global
discussion um but
maybe let me ask you how much of this do
you think is
permanent change or not permanent but uh
a new normal a new stable state
where where um urban jobs are
are deprioritized and people are back in
the countryside
or is this just something that we limp
through and there will be
you know we will revert back to what
things are like
before the pandemic how much of this do
we adapt to or how much of it do we just
endure
so i see some of the students from my
food policy class
here and what i talk about there is
the whole structural transformation that
we've seen historically with populations
moving from rural to urban areas and
that's the normal right that's how
most developed countries have gone and
that's where developing countries have
been going
um this crisis really raises the
question of whether we can do that
differently
and there is potential this i was just
having
a chat conversation here with david
and the idea of building
agri processing industry rural
enterprises
etc as new opportunities
for employing rural populations and
reducing the migrant flow is a way to
think about it and i think it can be
done
um in a more novel way with
smartphone technologies with icts
and social networks and
and other systems coming in now that
you can create much more exciting
employment opportunities
for rural youth today than you could in
the past
so i definitely think policy community
should be thinking about this more
seriously
can i head to that point there
i think if you're planning this world
indeed you'll have a reshift to focus in
rural areas and
rural production more young people going
out there but it's much more to it that
is
more maybe cultural and psychological
because if you look at you know in
africa how many of those people in urban
areas had jobs even before covered right
the easiest of course we've known that's
the law of
and happened they have gone to zimbabwe
last month and a lot of my cousins have
moved from
rural urban areas they've gone back to
rural areas now but
they're still saying is the moment this
is over we're all gonna kind of go back
and we all have this you know even here
in this part of the world that
as soon as this is over we're gonna go
back to the normal
so there is a little bit of a stickiness
to that
lifestyle that would require some
significant
re-education and change for people to
realign and
realize that the new normal is not going
back to
where you were before but we really have
this
mindset that you know anchors us to
opportunities whether they exist or not
in urban areas there's a poor then a law
that's gonna
require quite some education of
especially young people to realize
opportunities could be located somewhere
else but if you could fix it that way i
think this will be a long for long-term
benefit of
both develop food security and
development overall that
we can create opportunities in rural
areas as well
thank you ed rachel do you want to add
to that
i think i i agree that i think
part of the solution is trying to trying
to support
rural areas um there's been a real issue
here
in new york state with slaughterhouses
for example for local livestock
producers having access to adequate
uh places even though there's a rise in
demand they
there hasn't been adequate
slaughterhouse facilities for
local producers to to meet that demand
and that's part of a bigger picture
which is really policies and programs
which have really supported
large-scale producers and large
companies
at the expense of small-scale and
mid-sized producers
and you've really seen that in the
united states and that has hollowed out
uh rural economies um because fewer
people are living in rural places
there's fewer
businesses to support fewer producers
and and it's been devastating
in general for rural america and
and this uh pandemic has highlighted
that
more so i i would agree that supporting
um local and regional food producers and
distributors and
food-related businesses and making these
connections
between local consumers getting access
to healthy
diverse food sources um and and
supporting a regional economy is is a
very important
um learning that we should push for
um but it will require a shift in the
direction of
federal and state policy in general
which has gone in the opposite direction
thank you thank you rachel so we're 15
minutes over now
uh we can probably entertain one more
burning question if there is one from
the floor
anyone like to ask a final closing
question
all right uh with with that uh are there
any parting comments from the panel we
deeply appreciate you coming today it's
really been a treat to hear your
perspectives on this deeply appreciated
on behalf of
uh solo and crop sciences in the sips
community but any
parting comments um this will just
remind everyone this will be recorded so
feel free to
point other people to this that couldn't
make it today
i want to say that to me um this is a
this culvert pandemic is a new
class of uh natural disasters that you
know
best similarities with things that we've
had in the past but it's got some unique
aspects to it
the jury is still far from out so the
stories that we're writing today will
have to be rewritten
three or four times before we can
actually fully do a postmortem on this
so
i'm just aging that these are emerging
lessons and they're far from long-term
lessons
even though we're very quick to want to
make key conclusions out of this
i think we more of the effects will be
written
five years from now more volumes will be
written about this and what he did
to shape the nature of food security
around the world
i think what strikes me is some of the
food security and vulnerability
challenges
that we see in the developing world we
also see right here in new york state
and
and you know our communities are so
disattached that we work on
india or africa or the us but
cross learning is so limited between
what's happening in the u.s and what's
happening in the developing world then
it will be really interesting to build
those bridges
yes i i would agree probably i think
that we could learn a lot from
listening to each other's experiences um
but uh
i just want to thank thank you for
inviting us to this panel
andy and uh it's been a pleasure to talk
and to listen to each other so thank you
thanks again really great presentation
thank you everyone for attending have a
good day all right
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu